Hi, everyone. In this lesson, we're going to take a brief look at some lighting
tools that you have at your fingertips. So let's get started. So first up, we
have the Light Mixer. We also have the Environment Light Mixer, and we have
the Day Sequence. I'm going to briefly point out where they're at and
how to find them. And we're going to mainly focus on the Environment
Light Mixer because it just does some really great things really
quickly. Let's go and jump into Unreal, and I'll show you how they work.
Let's go ahead and make a brand new blank scene. So I'm going to go
new level, and we're going to say just an empty level. And we'll say
create. Now, say you're like, well, Sean, I don't know how to start
or get my lighting in the right direction. Well, Unreal's got you
covered. So if we go to Windows here, you're going to see a tool
called Environment Light Mixer. If we click on the Environment
Light Mixer, we can do several things. We can create what we
need as well as do any normal advance, which allows you to
actually populate all the things that you need to get your world
up and running. So any one of these should work just fine. So
I'm going to go and create and create a skylight. Next, you're
going to get an error. Don't worry about that because
Unreal's just waiting for other elements to build your
world. We're going to create directional light. We're going to
create a sky atmosphere. We're going to create a volumetric
cloud. And we're going to create a height fog. Look at
that. You are up and running. And it's given you all the
advanced features to be able to manage them and tweak them
and edit them within this little area here called the
Environment Light Mixer. And again, if you missed where I
found that, you can go to Windows and you'll see
Environment Light Mixer right here. There's also another
thing called a Light Mixer. Now the Light Mixer will
show you what is populating your scene. So you don't
have to necessarily dig for it inside of your outliner.
You can find it here. Pretty convenient. You can also use
a day sequence. Now to be able to turn that on, you
want to go to Plugins and you want to type in here day
and you're going to see day sequence. Already have mine
ready to go. Now we're going to go. We're not going to
dive too deep into that because that's for
atmospheric lighting course. But you can simply once you
have it active type in day sequence and you can see you
can get our base sequence actor as well as a few other
blueprint actors that we can use to our advantage to
build and to use for this particular tool. Now let's go
in and take some time and interactively alight a hero
object in unreal. In unreal I went to my class folder and
then I went to hero object in class. In here you'll
see the end and our beginning models to be able to
look at. Let's look at the end one just for a brief
moment. I'm going to say don't save on what we just
made. You can see I have a ship placed in our scene. If
I hit the G key we can see things without the
widgets. You can see we have a really nicely lit
simplified um scene here with our hero object in
place. Let's go back to that content folder and
click on hero VST. There we go. So let's start
from here. Automatically you will see that there's
glowing objects working in our favor using lumen. It
actually will recognize that in the material and
apply it to our scene. But unfortunately you're going
to see that there's a little bit of noise because
these this guy's a little bit smaller. It's not too
bad. But if we get any smaller we run into we
might run into some trouble and then we'll have
to adjust our project settings and so forth to
get things to work the way that we need. I
made the G key again just in case you're
missing any widgets and you'll notice that we
don't have any missing widgets in our scene. This
is raw object and platform. So let's go and
use that same tool we just used using that
environment light mixer with that open. I'm going
to go ahead and create a sky light, create a
directional light, create a sky atmosphere and
create a volumetric cloud and create a fog
height fog. Now we're completely lit but I want
to make things a little bit more moody. So I'm
going to go in here and grab my directional
light and I'm going to lower him a bit. So let
me click off that shadow search and let's lower
this to like maybe a one. If we want to tweak
it a bit further we can go ahead I'm gonna hit
the G key just in case it's missing. There
you go. Grid shows up too. I'm going to move
that up for a second so I can just see it in
place in context and I'm going to go ahead and
lower him to like a horizon really late night
environment. Maybe it's like a nighttime cyberpunk
environment. I'm going to lower the rotation
here you can keep it at the lowest if you can. And
I like to do that also with movement. So if I
decide to move the ship around or the lights,
and you can do the same thing with scale if
you wanted to you can move it to the lowest
possible one if you want. So let me see you
can do one more time. Oh, there we go. Very low
lighting. Excellent. Now, if you're getting hard,
or tweaky, I should probably say very
distinct reflections, like when we bring in the
rec light, you can lower the spec on this object
or the roughness. And that can help. We don't
have it yet, like I mentioned earlier, to be
able to remove the shape of those lights as
they show up in the scene. So let's get back
to it. So let's go ahead and do the lights
here. I'm going to go to lights. And we're
going to go ahead and add a rec light. This is
one of my favorite lights work with, because
they work really well for filling out your
lighting. Let's move it up here. And we're going
to stretch out him a bit more. And we're going
to end up softening the shadow when we do so.
So let's go ahead and rotate him a little bit
more towards the vehicle. And let's go ahead and
increase in the details, the source width,
decrease this to like maybe two for the
light. There we go. And we're going to mess
with the source height a little bit. There we
go. Nice little evenly lit object there. And
again, you can control how you want the
reflectivity to come in. Right now my roughness
is pretty low. So we're not getting the shape
of it in here. So that works out pretty
well. Or I should say the roughness is high
enough. So it's making the specular not come
through. I'm going to move this back just a
little bit. My attenuation radius is active. So
you can see that sphere around my rec light.
Now remember, rec lights are the most
expensive. And if we run into problems where
say we're lighting a whole cyber cyberpunk
environment, we can switch to mega lights
and see how it's performing. I'm gonna go
ahead and go to back the lights again, I'm
gonna add a point light. This point light,
we're going to give it kind of a blue tint,
we're going to magnify that glow on the
bottom. And we're going to lower his
strength. So it's very, just enough to sell
the idea. And we're going to move that down
here. There we go. That actually works pretty
well. Now if we want to, we can position a
little bit better. So it's basically a little
bit closer to that shape that's present. And
we also want to make sure both our lights
are movable. So I'm gonna click on this
one. Let's make it movable. So it's using
that full amount of lumen information. And
let's make sure our lumens fully on. So
let's go ahead and create a post process
volume. Don't want to forget that part. It's
easy to forget, even I working on working
in real for years, I can't forget, this is
really important, because it manages our
quality control. There we go. Let's get that
going. With this guy set in place, we don't
necessarily have to have him shape to the
object here, we can go ahead, like I
mentioned before, turn on lumen. And our
reflections here, we'll turn the others in
just a bit. But we also want to make sure
that this infinite extend unbound. So let's
go back up to quality control, global
illumination, turn this on, it's going to
use our project settings, that's fine. So if
we need to change any of these, we can surface
catch, hit lighting, let's do hit lighting
for reflections, lumen scene detail, let's
bump that on. Let's remove some of the
noise, view distance, we'll keep it as
normal final gather, it's kind of
important. So let's get better quality
here, we'll bump this up. And screen
space traces, we can tweak this out if we
wanted to, you can see that shift there a
little bit, we'll leave that on, it works
pretty well. Max distance, in sync, capture,
catch resolution. And you'll notice there's
advanced This is if we want things to
update if we're moving the light around.
All these defaults should work just fine to
start out. But as your scenes become heavier,
you may find yourself wanting to bump these
up a bit. So that things, these first two
so that things update on the fly a bit
better. So we got here screen traces, we'll
turn that back on again, high quality
translucent reflections, we really don't have
anything translucent. So we can probably turn
that off in this particular case. But we
can turn on some of these other things
such as our max rough traces. So again,
you can bump this up, you'll notice it
shifts, whether we want to lower it, or
increase it, and you can get more of a
shininess. And you'll see the hotspots
kind of come through a little bit more.
It's an overall sweeping control, max
reflection bounces, let's bump this up to
maybe three. And again, we have max
refraction bounces, let's bump this up
also to something like a five is fine.
Now, the reason why you want to be careful
with these because even though you may
want to crank them up, your eye is
probably not going to pick them up after
you after you go a certain point, it
definitely will not. So keeping it at
five or four, maybe just fine. And
you'll, you'll be doing just great.
Alright, so now let's go ahead and bring
in the rest of our lights. So let's
bring in our rec light. And we're
going to get this to be a bit of a
rim light for us. Now we can add a
texture source if you wanted to, and I
can mention before, we're not gonna do
in this particular case, we're gonna
mess with the source width, and the
source height. We'll leave it at eight
just for a second, but we're gonna
have to shift that probably in just a
bit. I'm going to set that to a 90
degree angle, and then rotate this
little bit of 45 degree angle, move
it back, and make sure that we're
shining on our object. Now, if you
want to you can increase the
strength of it, or decrease it. Now
we're kind of facing the opposite
direction. So let's swing that back
around. I knew that looked a little
weird. I'm like, what is it so weak
sauce? Give that four for now. That
being four, let's actually make it so
it doesn't cast shadows. So it's
more of a mood thing and not
necessarily a definite, it's up to
you, you can leave it casting
shadows if you want to, you can
experiment with some of the C bars
that I gave you, it's up to you.
But let's at least change the
color in this particular case. There we
go. And let's get a little bit of
back rim lighting here. So we can
use a spotlight if you wanted to,
and why not? Typically, I'll use
another rec light, but we'll just
use a spotlight just for the heck
of it. So let's bring the
spotlight. Let's move him back.
And let's really open up that
cone angle. Now you can use
these cone angles in such a way
which is really kind of nice. And
it can act like a full sweeping
rec light, simply just by the
way you position it, and the
amount of strength. And you can
get a quick rim light if you
wanted to. That's really up to
you and what you're looking for.
Again, I prefer the rec light a
bit more. But just for the heck
of being able to use all the
lights, we'll do this. And
make sure we angle that
accordingly. Okay. And again,
we can mess with our outer
cone angle if we wanted to
really kind of stretch it out a
little bit. Bring that light
in, get that kind of rim
light go in there. There we
go. We can strengthen it, change
its color to whatever we need.
There you go. Looks like city
lights are kind of shining on
it. So we have our fill, we
have our key, and we have our
back. Now if we want to, we
can put another one back here,
another light. And let me hit
the G key and see how we're
doing. And not too bad. Look
at that. Got a little cyberpunk
action going on. And again,
you can duplicate this and
change it any way that you
want. Remember to keep all your
lights movable. So we go back
in here, make a movable, make
sure he's movable. This one I
think already changed. Yes.
And we can simply grab this
rec, give my finger the L
key, or excuse me, alt, move
that around, rotate it. And
then we have another fill. And
we can change that to like a
red or green. They can really
try to capture the city lights
of cyberpunk city. There you
go. Anything that you want.
It's up to you. That's the
nice thing about working with
Unreal. It's like a big box
of 3d Legos. You can make
it do whatever you need and
want. Now for the G key.
There we are, we made a really
cool kind of cyberpunk lit
object. Quick and easy. Hit the
G key again, make sure that
that light is movable. And
that's it. Hope all of you
have enjoyed this course. We're
going to real quickly recap
what we've learned. And we
will wrap things up. Thanks
again.